you were born and raised in Scotland is
it true that you are not supposed to
wear anything under your kilt it's an
absolute must really oh yeah absolutely
absolutely you wear nothing well you're
supposed to wear nothing like and often
you check where your friends come out
you're like all right what that's a bit
of boxes don't what are you doing good
you know nothing so yeah no the real man
how could you wear a kiss the real men
yeah yeah
so when you we can't even get that right
when you wear a kilt you're totally just
free balling it I guess that's a way to
describe it yeah you're freeballing and
you normally do it at weddings by the
end of the night you're like yeah
we would not survive in Hollywood for
very long because it's like oh it's a
very Scottish thing to go have a look
there
have you ever done that yes I will yeah
yeah of course